toi ton problème tu arrives pas à
choisir et donc tu as décidé de
rencontrer deux femmes exactement voilà
exactement exactement donc on va revenir
là-dessus
le seul problème c'est qu'une fois en
face l'un de l'autre n'ayez pas grand
chose à vous dire c'est la date la plus
malaisante de l'année regarder et Margot
[Musique]
par jour c'est quoi que tu as fait à tes
cheveux là
OK
[Musique]
de rigoler
les chanteurs de rails
[Rires]
ma famille
j'aime bien l'idée donc voilà donc là
c'est sympa essaie de meubler quoi en
soit là on a regardé on a regardé
Margaux mais ça c'est aussi très bien
passé avec Clara alors justement on va
parler dans l'instant
si seulement il y avait que ce problème
mais je trouve que Manset hésitait donc
entre deux filles et il est devenu un
petit peu maladroit pour l'annoncer à
Margot c'était pas facile hein de dire
voilà que tu savais pas où ton zizi
voulait aller
dis-moi
[Musique]
tout ce que je t'ai dit je le pense
vraiment
[Musique]
elle va prendre ce qui lui correspond le
plus donc en soit tu vas essayer de
chaussures si le 43 est convient plus
que le 42
non en fait non
[Musique]
je suis pas compris
et là je prends conscience que je suis
dans une sacrée Paname du coup je vais y
aller
[Musique]
j'adore
l'administration
tu es pas contrôleur des impôts non non
et donc tu as rencontré Clara c'était ta
seconde prétendante et là c'est le drame
tu enchaînais gaffes mais c'est ça qu'on
aime bien chez toi
moi je suis quelqu'un de maladroit là
j'ai pris conscience de mon erreur
pourquoi parce que en fait il y a deux
femmes qui me plaisaient bon ben d'un
côté j'étais un petit peu départagé et
en soit ce que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai
été honnête j'ai été ma personne parce
que en soit les situations comme ça dans
la vie de tous les jours ça arrive ça
arrive énormément
[Musique]
[Rires]
regarde alors on va voir ce qui s'est
passé avec Clara
et j'ai vu une autre fille aussi
aujourd'hui
du coup j'ai aussi parlé avec elle et le
problème c'est que en fait vous avez
toutes les deux des choses qui me plaît
plaise tu m'intéresses vraiment
elle aussi elle me plaît c'est vrai toi
aussi mais
tu prends mal tu lui as dit la même
chose ou pas oui mais voilà
je suis dans un bourbier c'est ce qu'on
va faire
alors la vie de ma mère que j'ai du mal
avec le Carla et là alors je vais te
laisser réfléchir
[Musique]
je te laisse réfléchir je te jure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas trop quoi dire je me plais un peu et
il y a eu une couille dans le potage
comme on dit dans le potage et une
couille
tu avais pas prévu qu'elle se croiserait
dans les couloirs la production ils sont
forts on aurait fait pareil
[Rires]
on aurait fait exactement pareil donc
voilà ça fait rencontrer dans les
couloirs et c'est vrai que c'était pas
une excellente nouvelle pour toi c'est à
dire que j'étais dans un guet-apens là
je me disais aussi
[Musique]
vous êtes très forte
coalition en fait on a décidé un petit
truc
c'est que on allait rester
au château et du coup que tout est
débile
vraiment je suis ravi bah c'est nickel
c'est super
un peu trop joué
bonne soirée bonne soirée bonne nuit
[Applaudissements]
quand même pas le poupée de me justifier
quand même de d'envoyer un message à
carrelage
vraiment du mal en vrai
mais au final non
ils sont pas accrochés
merci tu as trouvé l'amour toujours pas
d'accord
[Rires]